MICHAEL CHOW: Hi, my
name is Michael Chow.
And thanks for watching
this RStudio conf talk.
I'll be going
through siuba, which
is a port of dplyr to Python.
So you're watching
RStudio conf, I'm guessing
that you're on board with R
and dplyr for data analysis.
And I've got to say, I love
R, but I also love Python.
And depending on
the project or task,
I've often found myself having
to switch between R and Python,
or juggle both at the same time.
And I'm guessing this isn't
a super unusual experience
since Python is just
incredibly popular.
If you look at Stack Overflow
posts, the predominant tool
in Python for data analysis,
pandas accounts for about 3%
of posts a month.
This is just an
incredible amount.
And so a lot of my
interactions have
been with people who use
pandas for data analysis.
But as time has gone on, I found
myself reaching more and more
for dplyr.
And I've really thought
a lot about that
and tried to figure out
what's going on there.
And to set the stage, I thought
I'd just use a dumb analogy.
That pandas is a lot maybe
like a double decker bus.
So this is in Hong Kong.
And this thing's really
built for carrying capacity.
If you have to ship
80 humans somewhere,
this is your tool, right?
You stack them on top of
each other you're golden.
The challenge is that
it's cumbersome, right?
It can't go everywhere.
It's probably scary to back up.
And in contrast, in
Hong Kong, there's
another vehicle, the
mini bus or siuba
that's the opposite
approach, so tiny capacity,
holds like 16 people, and
it's just a terror on wheels.
So the BBC describes it as
Hong Kong's wildest ride.
And these things are just fast.
They can go anywhere
and they can get you--
they're super flexible.
So I think that
really reminds me
of dplyr that dplyr's incredible
for exploratory analysis.
It can just get you to where
you want to go quickly.
Pandas is great at computation
but can be a little bit
cumbersome on the fly.
So siuba aims to
be small but mighty
by leveraging dplyr
like syntax in Python
but doing computation behind
the scenes in pandas or SQL.
And I've tried to live code
with siuba just of battle
test it and make sure it's
ready for the big time.
I think a big question
is what dplyr is really
doing that's so useful?
And to really
understand, we have
to go back to
Hadley's 2014 talk,
where he introduced dplyr.
And he mentions
that analysts have
two bottlenecks, a
cognitive bottleneck
and a computational bottleneck.
The computational one's
the most we think of,
the one we think of
most often, which
is as the data
becomes bigger, it
takes longer to run the code.
But intriguingly,
Hadley mentions,
he thinks a lot about the
cognitive bottleneck, which
is how should we
think about the data
and describe what we want
to do to the data or code.
And dplyr aims at this
cognitive bottleneck
to help people
focus their thoughts
and to give people
strategies for data analysis.
It does this by slimming
down, taking this big space,
and slimming down the
options that people have.
So there are five simple verbs
and all of these critically
can combine with an
operator group_by.
All of these take a data
frame and return a data frame.
And he mentions that overall,
it's a very constrained design,
especially compared to
his previous tool, plyr.
So siuba aims to let people
capture those dplyr-like thoughts
and keep them while writing
dplyr syntax in Python
and then doing the
computation in pandas.
So the gist is siuba
lets you transfer
your thoughts from R to Python.
All right, so I'm going to try
to show three motivating cases,
where it can be
tricky to transfer
dplyr thoughts to pandas through
roadblocks that people hit.
And I know it's
tempting to see dplyr
and pandas is pretty similar.
So in this example, they're
doing roughly the same thing
and they're using
basically the same code.
So it's a group summarize.
We're calculating the
average of a column
and we're renaming
the result average hp.
And we get roughly
the same output.
But it's also
worth noting if you
take to somewhere like,
Twitter, or look around,
you'll see some pretty
scathing reviews.
So dplyr has forever
ruined pandas for me.
Or Chelsea notes, every
picture shows pandas and chaos.
And I think it's worth noting,
these people, I think they
like pandas so this isn't a
straight critique of pandas.
But it can be really
frustrating when
you try to go from
one tool in the way
it structures
thinking to another.
And so I would say,
these three cases
try to bring that to the
surface what's going on.
The first roadblock is select.
So select is really
a very basic action.
You can choose columns.
You can drop columns.
You might match certain
columns or rename a column.
And the trick is that
pandas uses different names
for all these actions.
So there are four different
methods one for each action.
The other thing is
that sometimes they
have funky arguments
you need to pass.
So you might have to say
access equals 1 to say,
oh, I want to do
this to the columns.
Or you might have to
say columns equals.
Those are different ways
of saying the same thing.
The last is that sometimes you
have to use intense programming
constructs like a
Lambda function,
if you want to do things
like match on a string.
In contrast, dplyr uses the
same verb for all these actions,
select.
And it's really easy to
change between what you're
doing to go from keeping a
column to dropping a column,
or even to combine
these actions together.
And so this is a case, I think
of, where changing what you do
requires changing
gears and shifting
between these
different functions
and methods in pandas.
The second example is
I would say, group_by.
And this is really--
I would say grouping is
really a critical activity
in data analysis in dplyr.
And the pandas docs describe
some translations from R
to pandas.
And it looks pretty
straightforward,
at least for these cases.
But actually, I
would say group_by
in dplyr and pandas use
radically different underlying
grammars.
So in this example,
on the left, I'm
showing a filter in
pandas or a mutate.
And note, there are two ways
of doing it or multiple ways,
I should say.
So you can use query,
that's the top left
or eval on the top right,
or an alternative way
to filter on the bottom
left to these blocks,
or to mutate assign
on the bottom right.
Critically, we can
ask what happens
when we try to group_by
before these operations?
And the answer is that
none of them work.
And the trick is a group data
in pandas,a data frame
group_by, actually doesn't have
even any of these methods on it
to perform these operations,
except in one case, where
the operation just fails.
And this is probably
really surprising, I think,
for dplyr users.
The trick ends up being have to
shift the groupby from outside
of the verb to inside it.
So you basically
have to move group
by into your column operations.
And again, this isn't
necessarily bad.
And it means pandas can still do
the same computations as dplyr.
It's just I think
surprising for dplyr users.
And for me, challenging,
to do when I'm
trying to analyze data quickly.
The third roadblock,
I'd say, is SQL.
So dplyr users, if you're
like me, working in industry,
I lean on dplyr and dbplyr being
able to generate SQL heavily.
So you can just swap out
your data source to SQL
and player will generate
the SQL query for you.
In contrast, if
you're using pandas,
you just need to
switch to writing SQL.
And that's what I see happen
quite a bit in industry
is once it hits the
database, people just
switch and start coding SQL.
So your computation
changes and how you code
ends up changing as a result.
So to recap, dplyr
is really powerful.
It uses one verb,
select, for all the cases
for grabbing columns.
For group_by, you have this
really nice expressive syntax,
where you can modify
the full table action.
So you can have a
group to mutate,
or group filter,
or group summarize.
In contrast, pandas is
computationally powerful.
And it's packed with options.
But that means
that you might have
to do a little bit more work
up front during the analysis.
And this makes it great
for engineering but maybe
a big challenge, I think,
for exploratory data analysis
or quick analysis.
All right, so we looked
at some core challenges
in translating dplyr thoughts
about data analysis to pandas.
Now I want to switch
gears and look
how siuba can help you basically
preserve those thoughts
and code them in Python.
And it aims to do
this as faithfully
to dplyr as possible.
So I'm going to show
you an example of going
from dplyr code to siuba.
I apologize, I know I start
with these parentheses
and put the pipe at the
beginning of the line
and some people hate that.
I'm sorry.
My bad.
So let's go ahead and
just start the switch.
So first, we'll
change our imports.
So rather than using library,
we'll do our Python imports.
Then we'll change the pipe to
be greater than greater than.
Next, we'll put
an underscore dot
in front of the variable names.
And this has to happen in order
for it to be Python syntax.
And then the last thing
is a little bit tricky.
We're going to take
this mean function call
and we're going to
change it to a method.
So it's more similar to how
pandas expressions operations.
All right, and so in a sense,
with these few simple changes,
we've gone from dplyr
in R to siuba in Python.
And looking side by
side, hopefully my goal
is that you can squint
your eyes and they just
look like the same code
and you can just figure out
how to swap between them.
So now, I want to go
through the three examples
that I showed before
and just give you
a sense for what they
look like in siuba.
So the first
roadblock was select.
And now looking back at this
example with siuba on the left,
it should be basically
the same thing,
now you just have underscore
dot variable names.
It's worth a read to
the very bottom one
where you select
certain columns.
It's really easy to
do and it matches up
with the pandas code.
So pandas, you can do this,
dot str dot ends with,
and it will return true
whenever a column matches that.
And siuba just lines up with
that way of doing things,
so corresponds to
the pandas way.
The second example is group_by.
So we showed a
few different ways
of doing filter and mutate.
So the filter and mutate now
for pandas are on the right.
And let's show
how siuba does it.
So here's the siuba filter
and mutate on the left.
Notice that they're eerily
similar hopefully to dplyr.
And we can just tuck in the
group_by above the filter
and mutate to make it a
group filter or group mutate.
So it's meant to be easy
to just swap in and out.
The last example was SQL.
So I think this is the biggest,
most useful part of siuba
is you can swap out your data
source from being a pandas data
frame to a SQL alchemy--
essentially a SQL alchemy
connection and siuba
will generate the single
query, or run the query
and return a table of
data just like dplyr.
And right now, it's mostly
Postgrgsql and redshift
that I've worked on
supporting but it can
be extended to more back end.
So there's early support
for my SQL and SQL Lite,
and I'm hoping to build
those out further.
I think one of the
incredible things
is that you get ggplot for free.
And that's not by
any of my work.
But by the work
of a person named
Hassan, who built
a package called
plotnine, which is an incredibly
faithful port of ggplot.
So ideally, you can just do the
full data transformation, data
visualization.
And you can carry over your hard
earned skills from R to Python.
So just to recap, siuba tries
to use a very similar syntax
to dplyr.
There are some cases
where it needed
to be tweaked a little
bit to be Pythonic
or to just be Python syntax.
And incredibly, it aims to
bring you SQL and ggplot.
And I found that
these things really
help me get back up to
speed in data analysis
and have been fun to
just to carry into Python
and to discuss with people.
All right, so we talked
about three roadblocks
you might face when translating
dplyr code and thoughts
to pandas and how siuba you
roll past those by essentially
copying and pasting
dplyr into Python.
Now I want to zoom out
a little bit and ask,
why is siuba worth
in the long term?
Why should you try
out or adopt siuba?
And the first thing I
want to hearken back
to is Hadley's point in 2014
about cognition and computation
that D dplyr as a
cognitive tool has,
if you've used it over
long term, probably
really helped you build skills
to ask important questions
of your data.
And those skills aren't
even maybe that related
to programming.
So why not just bring those
skills with you into Python?
The next point is siuba
uses dplyr's architecture.
And this lets it very
flexibly add new back end.
So whether you run
against SQL or pandas,
siuba can support it.
And I'm hoping to extend
support to Python specific tools
in the future like
dask and tools
like spark as well as
fleshing out mySQL support.
The next thing is
that siuba runs
just an enormous glut of
continuous integration tests.
So it's incredibly
thoroughly tested.
I would say it's
paranoid about ensuring
that you get the same
result back, whether you're
running on SQL or pandas.
And every time I push code,
it runs thousands of tests.
The last thing is
developer docs.
So I've tried to leave a
nice trail of breadcrumbs.
So if you're curious about
the internal workings of siuba
or looking to
patch or extend it,
there are just enormous
resources to do that.
I'd suggest the
programming guide
in the siuba docs, which goes
through all of siuba's parts.
Or I have something called
architectural decision records
and GitHub that document
key decisions I made,
why they were made, and contain
sketches of those decisions.
The last thing is if you're
interested in learning siuba,
there's some nice
alleys you can go down.
So the first thing I'd recommend
is Dave Robinson's Tidy
Tuesday's screencasts.
These are actually an R,
so maybe, not as related,
but they were an
incredible resource
when developing siuba and
actually a big motivation
to work on it.
I think being able to
see a person move quickly
through data analysis
in a holistic setting
is really important.
And Tidy Tuesday
is a project that
releases new data every week,
lets you see things in action.
The other thing is there's
an interactive tutorial
for siuba on learn.siuba.org.
So if you're curious
to just get started,
even if you've
never coded before,
the tutorial's made to make
it easy to get started.
It's something I've tested
on my family, and friends,
and I'm really excited for
the opportunity for siuba
to make it really
easy for learners
to take their first steps
into coding and data analysis.
The last thing is
that I've tried
to put up live analysis on
YouTube of analyzing data
for an hour, whether
it's translating
Dave's analysis from
R into siuba, Python,
or doing Tidy Tuesday
analysis for an hour.
So I highly recommend
watching those,
if you want to see
siuba in action,
and then trying and siuba
out on Tidy Tuesday.
Just take it for a spin
and see what it looks like
and how it compares, say, to
using R or another Python tool.
So just to recap, you
can find siuba on GitHub
at machow/siuba.
You can pip install it.
I can't highly recommend
Tidy Tuesday enough.
It'll let you get a feel for
what data analysis with siuba
looks like.
And there's learn.siuba.org.
If you've never coded, I've
tried to design this for you.
And I'd love to see people take
their first steps into data
analysis through this course.
So thanks to everybody who
helped contribute to siuba.
Thanks to RStudio for
putting this together.
And thanks to the army of people
who gave feedback on this talk
and made it much, much better
than its first version.
So thanks for watching.
I hope you'll try siuba out.
And if you have any
questions, please
feel free to reach
out to me on GitHub
or on Twitter @chowthedog.
Thanks.